yeah hello and welcome to this video
yeah I've made some recordings yesterday
and there was a common debts the sound
wasn't too great I think it should be
better now I had actually made a pretty
sunny mistake in the setup so I think it
should be a lot better now so got a
Petroff modern main line I'm playing
with 96 Bishop e6 as I also recommend in
my recently released repertoire series
on this on this opening c4 that's a bit
of the reverie team I can't even go d5
which is probably just completely okay
yeah I think this is the cleanest move
let's aim after which I definitely am
okay it's a bit on the bit on the doubt
side though admittedly but I have
absolutely no problem him I think he
cannot cast so long as I can take a -
yeah so here what is it
this is taking on f3 somehow an option
yeah it doesn't lead to all that much
it's a way to get a little bit of
imbalance though in this position okay I
mean I can't castle Castle queenside
host I can always take if I want to
Oh mm yeah I didn't like to take I
really don't like to take I mean it's an
imbalance but nothing particularly great
I think I'm trying just to play on my
somewhat more active pieces now let's
see what happens him oh he just wants to
wants to double their okay yeah it's
probably not a bad idea okay I want to
trade one rook that is some probably the
way to go if he want to try to create
something out of this position which is
stuff
yeah d5 was a bit lame and maybe it kind
of proves um then white had absolutely
nothing but it's also not the kind of
the kind of continuation that gives you
any great winning ideas with black so
it's a bit it's a bit lame
when c4 isn't that that fantastic anyway
so probably premiere shouldn't have done
that
for the sake of from getting more
interesting play that same I came
okay see try does he try to do something
I don't know I mean one thing is clear
you can always in such a position try to
outplay your opponent in an end game
it's it's possible more often than you
think so okay I'm taking this and now
for example this before idea I don't
know it doesn't doesn't look all that
great to me
I'm going to fix his pawns there on dark
square say he's got a dark squared
Bishop so it's a little a little bit of
a concession now if I can get the Knight
to c4 that would be really nice it's not
easy to do his rook is a little bit odd
damn it
medium is probably going to play Bishop
before I ever play this night no I don't
want to do that okay so I'm going to
make a waiting move I'm a little bit
down on time then that's something that
I have to keep in mind should not forget
that okay so why am I not just winning
this point I have no no I think I can
just take it home
what's the deal
look p3 or something like that
no would be three I can even check on c2
if I like yeah I can take on c2 King
takes rook c4 check he's able to take me
five though is that something better
even know let's take it it's not really
so comfortable keeping an eye on this is
this one and I'm threatening c6 c 685
Bishop c3 chick there's a small threat
sorry for the sound in the background
oops come on
I asked Alba should've ate at the end I
have to a saying as well no that's good
so I'm keeping my phone at seven seconds
that's not great and it's not so easy to
win in the first place because of the
low pawn count
okay so how to do that probably c5 you
should be sure to f6 and then push
further yeah okay
okay I'm out of the danger zone in terms
of time that's really important
it wasn't a good idea how can I get the
King closer hmm I don't want to play a
fire freely that's not a move I want to
play that's a that's a repetition now
that's very silly and maybe I cannot win
anyway but I was very silly hmm okay
well so you know 95 85 kind of Proof Set
c4 is the lemon in terms of advantage
but it's just a bit bit bit boring
really
oh we can actually cancel own mouth
because of Queen to c3 I would I would
ouch ouch so d5 is actually bad I mean
it's clear that I can do something like
castles short here because well
wide usually goes Queen side but c4
doesn't help there I mean I get this in
very quickly so I should just cancel a
Castle kingside and I completely
overlooked that he can do this and he
has this month which is extremely strong
getting a double attack and basically I
have no good move him Wow there was a
very bad move t5 okay yeah now this is
just absolutely nothing from a white
I have equalized username I'm a bit
intrigued that the engine says castle in
Queens I thought I can take really okay
once the play but should be five for
compensation interesting because this is
not possible I have the check in okay
III being played and this is just equal
but as we saw I got a little something
so trade one rook this is a good way to
do it so I keep one rook just have more
ideas to play with and yeah b5 is kind
of normal I'm fixing his pawns on dark
squares and yeah yeah h3 85 and now he
went Bishop c5 which is a weird decision
I was thinking c3 and okay the engine is
just very much
yeah claiming equality which is probably
true it I'm already a bit I mean I'm
happy yeah because he's got some points
on that squares if you imagine I would
play him and then the idea would be to
bring a Bishop to c4 would be a Knight
to c4 would be great then this is the
weakness and so on yeah I got some ideas
here I mean it's probably equal on it
same yeah why does this should draw this
but it's it's rather black who can't
rhyme yeah and he just he just gave me
that pawn yam cakes and tea I was
struggling a little bit with the time I
think if I would have had a little bit
more time I probably could have played
this better
so yeah iam I'm not really certain his
ending as a win
yeah maybe it is I don't know
so we can actually look at the game yeah
here the engine doesn't want to take but
still I don't think it's a mistake so I
was getting getting to this which is
already quite good and I wonder if there
is a way to now I got a king d for now
[Music]
not entirely certain if there is a hell
was that helps really I mean at the end
I made this drawing by repetition which
is very silly word so how does that help
okay like Bishop you won I get to e3
okay it is a win mathematically it's the
engine as the engine confirms so I'm
shielding against this and okay so
[Music]
okay so you know he has to basically
stay here and then I'm getting getting
this and mmm okay yeah yeah it is a win
then but I couldn't do it ahead and I
had no time I mean I could do it I just
ran into the silly repetition being
irritated somehow anyway I hope you
still enjoyed the game thanks for
watching